so I've been playing tears of the
Kingdom recently as is
everyone else as it seems I go on
Twitter and that is all I see I go to
work and that's all we're talking about
I start a meeting and it's 10 minutes
until we actually talk about work and
yet it's a single player game I'm
playing it alone but I feel
like I'm playing it with everyone like
take a look at this every time I boot my
switch up without fail every person
online is playing tears of the Kingdom
okay well almost everyone this is a game
that invites you and you alone to go on
an adventure but somehow I feel more
connected with the players around me in
the real world in most multiplayer or
any game for that matter can manage to
accomplish so
how is a single player game
even accomplishing this
[Music]
the whole thing has kind of had me
thinking about the idea of connection
even kind of nostalgic for it because
back in the day before the internet and
if you wanted to like share something
you found in a video game you'd have to
like go back to the schoolyard with your
friends and like talk it over like in
those days it's almost like information
was like fantastic it was like this
wonderlust thing that you'd like covet
and share with someone else like some
sort of secret and somehow in a post
internet World cheers the kingdom
manages to captured that
these guys are sharing all sorts of
secrets about video games they're flying
at that yeah I'm looking at your house
now the internet and maybe this is like
a cynical point of view but I feel like
it's sort of paved the way for the
extinction of that sense of wonder when
you're sharing information with a friend
and I guess maybe the adult equivalent
to that playground sort of feeling is
like the water cooler discussion but
even then that's just a banter of
opinions over whatever show you've been
watching on Netflix but tears of the
Kingdom rekindles that child like sense
of Discovery and wanting to share it
with other people when I go online and I
see the things people are sharing the
discoveries they're making the
inventions they're crafting I don't see
them as spoilers I see someone's own
approach it's like a snapshot into their
own adventure and in that way it's
almost like the internet has Amplified
it more than softened it because in most
cases I'm in just complete awe of what
people are doing and it just makes me
all the more eager to immediately Rush
my game and try and do it for myself and
it's also just
stupidly addicting
the moment players leave the Sky Island
area the way in which each of us choose
to explore the rest of the world has
felt so unique and completely different
I for one saw a big old hole in the
ground and said it I'm jumping down
that others want to find a Taino Village
some went to find the tears others
hunted down shrines it all feels
distinct to the player and that's really
it tears of the kingdom and the way in
which players choose to explore its
World in a lot of ways kind of feels
like an expression of their creativity
even maybe their personalities like I
for one have spent 50 hours in that game
since it's launched and I have not done
a single Temple sorry Zelda you're gonna
have to wait a little longer until I
find you but that's what makes no one's
experience the same but still inspiring
to listen to seeing someone share
something online that's just absolutely
mind-boggling something you would have
never been able to figure out or put
together on your own
feels like that schoolyard wonder and
that it just makes me want to rush back
to the game and try it for myself and
the abilities the game gives you to
solve problems to explore are in so many
ways these tools of creation hear me out
it's sort of like mimicking someone
else's art you can attempt someone
else's style but it's still going to be
an interpretation that is your own so in
trying to do something that someone else
did you're actually kind of recreating
experience through your own lens which
makes it distinct to you and even just
like saying that uh in this context of a
game I don't remember the last time I've
ever spoken about a single player game
like this if ever in fact let's actually
talk about single player games for a sec
because there's been an interesting
Trend this year that I kind of want to
diverge into the most successful games
of this year are actually in fact single
player games Jedi Survivor was the top
selling game of April Hogwarts Legacy
has made a billion dollars tears of the
Kingdom sold 10 million in just three
days and Resident Evil 4 remake is the
second fastest selling game in the
entire Resident Evil franchise they're
all single player games and they are
just dominating the charts now yes of
course those are all gargantuan IPS that
are basically just made to print money I
know that but
with multiplayer games that are also
banking on big IPS the track record for
those are far more dire
Marvel's Avengers is shutting down this
year Gotham Knight's reception was well
really rough there also seems to be a
lot of skepticism and criticism around
Suicide Squad which is walking in
similar footsteps to Gotham Knights and
it doesn't help that it's also a looter
shooter and speaking of looter Shooters
this isn't a gargantuan IP but let's
talk about redfall this was Studio
arcane's first big multiplayer game
under the Xbox
umbrella and was supposed to be a big ol
hoot as a day one game pass game but its
launch has been disastrous which in of
itself is an interesting case study
Arcane is a studio known for its single
player games but has now been positioned
to make a multiplayer experience and in
doing so completely misses the mark on
what made them an identifiable studio in
the first place it's just is an
observation and I'm really not entirely
making a point it's just enough to have
made me think about tears of Kingdom's
success and the success of many other
single player games this year and just
kind of you know think about this pivot
that Studios have had back and forth
between multiplayer games and single
player games think about games like
tears of the Kingdom even the feeling of
online communities that have formed
around from software games albeit that
they still have multiplayer elements to
them it's interesting to see how
connections can still form even Thrive
from a solo experience let alone one
that transcends the idea of being just a
game and more about the personal stories
and Adventures we create for ourselves
in things like tears of the kingdom and
then get to share those stories among
friends now not every developer can be
Nintendo or from software just like how
every game can't Bank on enormous IPS
like Zelda Star Wars Harry Potter or
Marvel's Avengers it's just kind of been
an incredible reminder about the
connectedness a game can have with
people sometimes more than any other
medium like the ability to just want to
share something you're doing with
someone else just like me sitting here
talking to you about tears of the
Kingdom
okay
that's it for this week's episode of the
Curt Locker thanks for coming by
do you have your switch
why not
dumbass
because you don't care about Cora
no I do